thank you for your patience but that's
the first reason why I'm standing here
the second reason involves one word so
it's going to be quick that's great huh
one word and that word is duh
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm not done
[Applause]
[Music]
I've been waiting for this a long time
I'm not done
I didn't say duh was the end I just said
there's one word to describe why I'm
here and that's duh those guys
did you hear the little video where I
said listen listening is important
I was tasked with the job to try to
create an environment so we could have
some success
you know people you know you've got some
good players you got to do something
and I'm going to give myself credit I
did you know what I did I was there
I watched it all I saw it and I have
pictures to prove that I was there while
they won championships